[Music]
around the world since this weekend
there have been protests that mixed
sympathy with the US protesters and
anger at the US as well as anger over
local issues in places where people see
parallels to the situation in the u.s.
that minorities are being repressed that
police are restricting gatherings
protests with what they see as excessive
violence
it's just gut-wrenching the climate of
what's happening in America and it's
also happening here in Australia though
it's subtle the racism is real for me
in essence the u.s. protests have struck
a chord in many other countries around
the world
[Applause]
for many years the US has been the
world's moral voice on so many of these
issues when other countries have called
out the riot police started bashing
heads using water cannons rubber bullets
to your gasps the US has been there
urging calm wagging a finger Russia
China in this case they get to say well
look you're doing the same thing United
States so you have no authority to
criticize us for doing exactly what
you're doing
[Music]
yo jang hangjun vision yet so it's
highlight so you can together title
since allah some toy hi Miko trying
solid team young hype a song dancing
future late santo you hylian hang off a
song some dough high tone young bowling
se habla career choice a team a larger
conscience retire so it's fine you may
work quani from to t-shirt king
Hippolyta fun would he in Russia the
situation playing out in the US now is
that a probably at an emotional level
fairly disturbing too much of the world
to see the u.s. they're literally in
flames like this and and and in conflict
like this as has got to be traumatic